yeah what characters video playing sky
1016 from Malaysia I guess yeah malaysia
and turn let's see Queens gambit c60 ok
let's go on 93 see what line is coming
up with him g3 i recently studied and I
I liked for white but then I've cited
mostly from blacks point of view so not
familiar with this kind of setup it
looks a bit strange to me frankly
speaking but then let's see what happens
it looks much like a sloth with the
classic God's law but why does not I my
pieces are different let's put it that
way I managed to play g3 ok so easy for
a move hmm if only I can play Bishop c3
he takes f Bishop takes d4 and it is
interesting if he does not take on c3m I
just don't want a temple yeah yes sir he
doesn't mind ok I could take it out so
just play f3 here positionally ok let's
do that trying to shut out this Bishop
on g6 this is just looking at the for
porn all the time not doing much ok
game night I'll just queen bee three
queen bee three si good at symbols
making sure that d1 sm is a place for
the rook also getting night a tune into
the mix c5 I go d5 young I should I
should support this c5 I can play D 585
I'll also play d 5 this is important I
could also take actually if he takes a
five if you place d5 I could take its
maybe even a good move okay so all night
a 29 this was prepared all along he
cannot retreat it as I just take b7 and
if he cannot retreat that I'm going to
take it with a very good position if the
bishop is gone i have e 5 and 96cm yeah
this looks very good for white maybe he
needs to do something exactly after he
needs to do something something drastic
now cannot play a so-so move something
okay let's let's check my take be four
is going to take sea floor with the
temple so I need to I need to move the
night only question is where yeah
probably just back to e to be five of
course is some and you don't really want
to play it's very weakening bow
and maybe he has to but it's possible
taking with the rook on let's take with
the rook I guess before now trying to
interesting now this is interesting
playing for night c4
i also have a d5 here d 5 94 96 e te
textie to okay if I take twice on b5
night see for rookie to John I probably
should do that and not think about it
too long it sits upon its upon
maybe you can play a form I didn't think
about that at all maybe yeah maybe I can
do that Queen before takes Knight takes
he takes me five yeah it's got night c4
I have very very good defense that he
put up here okay didn't see ya didn't
see anything else and maybe Queen d3m
could have take windey three how to save
ya this of course was not what I had to
head in mind but it's still it's still
not them yeah nothing nothing terribly
bad happened here here we can play maybe
nine tanks
want to use the king hmm
maybe he intends to play at 5pm most of
all okay let's and let's try try 95
exchanging the snide if he goes Knight
b6 and I have be three
oh this is ambitious very ambitious play
yeah this is just a friendly word for
meaning bad i think not quite sure what
what the point of this is I mean he just
places his night on a bed square came
let's shut this down yeah one move
tricks thanks yeah like a split was just
just just in terrible shape before that
get the bishop on g6 white resigned yeah
I can I can just play any movie and I'm
great yeah maybe it's not it's not it's
not much but still like I just I just
take this and he just has misplaced it's
not it's just terrible move Knight evade
yeah it's probably still equal because
he can play can play that and this
should should be a draw I guess chanting
something like that it's probably a draw
yeah this will end in a draw i guess
yeah this was just just very
disappointing like is completely out
right here after the opening match if
you handed this nicely maybe i need to
play on play it Sam
different maybe I need to play
differently 95mm 95 was the calm
suggestion
yeah this is in fact bet I am it's
better I completely underestimated this
it's a very strange defense in my book
but it seems to work but the main point
is that after this I I completely
overlooked queen bee three I invested a
bit of time here but I simply forgot
that d3 as a valid square I only looked
at those and queen bee three I think
just refute this yeah okay then then I
play was ok i just need to play Queen d3
here after that there's not much not
much going on I still think that white
is better he's got the step bishop on g6
but probably it's not not the end of the
world this is just a just a strange move
why would you retreat the night it
doesn't have any square on a wait but
when anyway yeah if I play his stuff
like that you can play even moves like
neither wait alright thanks for watching